more now on the escalating violence in
Israel and the West Bank earlier we
spoke to middle east analyst Mayor Joe
vendor far in Tel Aviv everybody's
worried in the State of Israel we don't
know what to do how can you stop
somebody who of their own volition wake
up in the morning and decide to get a
knife and go and kill someone later on
that day there are free women they're
not on of a network and I'll telling
anybody they're just doing it themselves
it is the we just are other lost in
Israel as to how to fight this terror
threat and this is something that's
concerning Israelis from both the right
and the left spectrum of politics both
leaders are at a position where they
can't make any compromises this is what
makes the situation particularly
dangerous the past far the Palestinians
are concerned they made compromises
before they cooperated with it is run in
terms of security but all they got was
expanded settlements which they consider
as it slap in the face and in the
Israeli side well you know we hear oh
the incitement of the Palestinian
Authority Hamas is calling for the
destruction of the State of Israel and
Prime Minister Netanyahu if it shows any
flexibility his government will fold
apart so this is a situation where
neither side can make any compromises
and this creates hopelessness I mean
when there's hopelessness the extremists
thrive both sides need to make
compromises way in Israel also need to
make compromises the Palestinians also
need to make compromises both sides need
to learn something we in Israel should
by now learn that expanding settlements
has not and will not give us security
and the Palestinians and my Palestinian
neighbors I hope they will realize that
piles of dead Israelis stabbed on the
streets of Jerusalem and Tel Aviv will
not give them a state will not give them
a country and this is the realization
that both sides need to reach but until
then we are the situation it's a
freefall right now
and I don't think there's any foreign
power right now how can step in to
resolve the situation